[Musique]
monsieur
un coup de fusil
moi il me semblait qu'il y ait touché
mais les trottoirs pour vous révéler
tous les secrets du civet de lièvre
tourangeau je vous emmène aujourd'hui en
touraine bien sûr sur les bords du cher
dans un village d'indre et loire ne met
savonnières à une dizaine de kilomètres
de tout savonnières il faut que je vous
présente c'est le village chan
il y a quelques années en effet monsieur
dubreuil
un agriculteur de la commune s'est donné
pour mission de relancer l'élevage de
l'âne et il a convaincu la plupart des
habitants de la commune de suivre son
exemple
un nouveau nom vient donner à mon goût
de reviens y un bonbon viendront
hier en france vont bien
on
moi
où
[Musique]
c'est lui pour paume c'est du breuil oui
c'est le père de nos âmes que nous avons
à la maison à l'heure actuelle à c'est
le préféré de l'impression oui
malheureusement émis à quel âge il a 9
ans y'a combien dada savonnières en ce
moment au bien ma foi la savonnière
actuelle il y en a 80 et quelques noms
c'est sûrement le village de france où
il ya le plus grand nombre d'adp non je
le pense je pense nous faisons tous les
ans à notre fête la foire aux ânes et je
ne sais pas si en france il ya des
frères il ya uniquement entre des années
cette année on ne l'avait 150 et 450
tonnes qui étaient rassemblés
oui à la fête désigné dimanche ou way et
ça sort bien les ânes aujourd'hui encore
20 de ce moment faisant fort mal on est
à même de vendre des zones pas mal
pourquoi d'ailleurs
bon un peu tout quelques-uns pour
travailler mais c'est plutôt rare mais
alors ce qu'on vend surtout c'est pour
amuser des enfants puis enfin des gens
et qu'ils s'en servent comme tondeuses
pour couper l'aide du gazon qu'ils ont
lieu dans leur maison ils le mettent à
voter dans le pré voilà c'était un
animal de compagnie maintenant fait ah
oui oui c'est d'où d'ailleurs un âne
vous savez il y en a pas de méchants ni
ou très peu j'en prenais pas de marbre
tiens à vous mais non ça c'est
affectueux c'est avec tout ce beau monde
ah bon c'est pas têtus comme on le dit
non non puisque nous faisons les courses
les fêtes année tous et nous en ont fait
ce qu'on veut on leur fait sauter la
rivière on l'a fait tous sont télé
[Musique]
parce que vous faites des courses d'ânes
chaque année à tous les hameaux niel on
a un groupe sain avec un tiercé
oui oui on fait le diable c'est comme à
vincennes comme qu'obama les courses
d'ânes c'est le 1er août vous l'avez
noté
mais tout le reste de l'année rassurez
vous on est les ânes de savonnières mène
une existence beaucoup plus paisible
[Musique]
bon revenons à notre civet de lièvre
tourangeau c'est pour lui que nous
sommes venus et monsieur libre '
heureusement pour nous est aussi un
excellent chasseur c'est donc l'une des
pièces de son tableau de chasse que nous
allons voir préparer tout de suite par
sa belle mère madame a redit oui alors
madame mardi vous êtes prête à passer à
la préparation des cv on va commencer
oui ce poulet c'est bon on va commencer
peut-être par énumérer tous les éléments
qui sont nécessaires pour préparer le
civet il vous faut de deux bouteilles de
vin rouge environ oui plus ou moins
souvent grosseur de lieux martin pour
celui ci je crois que je sache et isolde
du persil est perçu une planche de
l'homme et une petite branche de thym et
puis une feuille de laurier du poivre du
poivre et du sel et puis deux trois
petites gousses d'ail a aussi j'avais
deux lueurs un peu puisque j'ai des
lardons besoin et puis à d'autres villes
avant était un petit verre de 10 pour le
flamber d'accord alors par quoi on
commence eh bien d'abord par faire
revenir les lardons et ensuite je vais
couper molière allez-y de lardons qu'est
ce que vous en faites
je vais faire aussi dans ma cocotte
musique avec quelques oignons à la
cuisinière
c'est vrai que j miro bois ça
toujours vous travaillez sur la
gazinière aubois ont ajouté les deux ont
su bien sûr le gasc sur le poids mais de
préférence sur le bois pourquoi je pense
que c'est une vieille habitude à moi
c'est d'ailleurs don most je ne sais pas
vous savez j'en connais pas la
différence
non simple pour moi j'aime bien la
cuisinière à bois
c'est une vieille tradition tourangelle
quoi de servir du bois quand on va les
voir autant de boulets bien sûr ça fait
des économies d'énergie on va laisser
revenir ça à feu doux à feu doux ça va
ça va alors faut attendre maintenant que
ça réussisse comme dans dame savoir
peut-être que peut-être cinq à dix
minutes ça va dépendre comme on fait va
aller mais enfin météorite minuit
d'accord et pendant ce temps là qu'est
ce que vous pouvez faire découper
molière par étant là
il est déjà pré découpés la presse
changement de la part d'un autre
il ya une façon de découper le lièvre on
oui mais monsieur ne suis pas un artiste
n'est pas un scoop ça un peu à la
couleur de mon esprit vous ne devez pas
mariner votre lièvre non celui ci je ne
veux pas rasé il ya des fois je fait
mariner mais celui-ci n'est pas et alors
qu'est ce que vous préférez vous moi je
préfère son mari nan mais celui
certaines personnes préfèrent la
marinade sélection bout donc c'est le
lierre symbole de balad a redit
aujourd'hui san marina de la marinade
bon et alors qu'est ce que vous en fait
être là ils ont les ongles ça ne brûle
pas oui c'est vrai la sava fallait pas
que si vous en faites de vollard dont
maintenant maintenant c'est à dire voyez
comme ils tremblent ils sont bien dorés
sont bien d'arrêt et tout le gras fondu
donc dans la boue dans la cocotte dans
la cocotte a même pas que les joyaux et
c'est là dedans que vous allez faire
jaillir
mais quand j'ai terminé mes morceaux
bien voilà vous voulez je vous le donne
le lièvre
s'il vous plaît merci monsieur
[Musique]
besson
vous ne mettez pas tout ça tout ça m'a
fait beaucoup d'efforts demandés plus
offrant
alors pour l'instant vous faites
simplement et au bout de 10 minutes
environ quand les morceaux de lièvres
sont bien isolés on les retire pour
faire le roux alors qu'est ce qui vous
pousse à ce rendez vous pour ma part je
vous la donne
voilà demandez moi vous dérangez pas bon
ouais
[Musique]
alors une bonne cuillère de nouvelles du
gabon depuis 40 ans d'âge à quoi bon a
priori donné un gros talent en dessin à
dos d'âne
cette circonstance et c'est aussi bon
après tout s'il vous plaît voilà merci
qu'est ce que c'est comme vin qui pour
le deuil des choix il va de la région
d'où la décomposition d'un collègue
combien vous en mettez 2 litres à trois
ans de bouteille de bouteilles de
puteaux
la femme a dit bourgogne ou de chinon
bref dans tout bon vin quand ils sont
tous rangés dans nos cerveaux directe
aurait donc il faut parce qu'il est bon
vous allez laisser mijoter là doucement
un peu de sel et peut-être aussi une
bande pensez quoi ouais c'est du gros
sel que vous avez la différence elle est
un peu de poil voilà déjà recours alors
là maintenant que sa tante qui me choque
et qu'il est temps qu'ils rentrent en
ébullition alors combien de temps après
ça dépend du feu comme on dit comme je
le fais et vif enfin mettez 5-5 6
minutes
bon bah temps nous asseoir à manger et
là vous devez être un peu fatigués n'ont
pas tant que là je vous avais mal à
mardi 59 à 64 19 ans soit attendait
franchi les magic donc à vous voyez pas
le temps passer on dirait un 80 devant
80 ans passés et vous faites encore la
cuisine comme ça dans la mine même temps
en temps oui vous avez de l'aide comme
un musicien à oreille a heureusement pas
ce que je pourrais pas te faire
maintenant c'est de laisser passer
oui et vous aimez ça faire la cuisine
j'ai mes chats mais maintenant que ce
que voulaient j'ai fait mon temps je
pense que relayer aux autres on apprend
ainsi que luis corrons aime bien la
bonne chère vous avez le bon appétit
dans la famille oui avrillon % c'est
bien ils apprécient votre cuisine sais
pas s'il apprécie la manche et la manche
où d'après ces gros signe alors
maintenant que ça bouge on met
aujourd'hui
et maintenant alors qu'est ce que vous
allez faire je vais tâcher de le faire
clan belle si je me fie à moyen aux là
on a une belle flamme la wii c'est fini
il est fort mais bon qu'est ce qu'il
vous reste à faire maintenant il est
l'heure dont les larves ans pour les
ajouter donc voilà sur le tube mont
bouquet garni et je les suis le bouquet
est le sens de lier la calabre en fin de
cuisson le sens donc au dernier moment
pour l'instant un peu d'ail
voilà la belle maintenant y'a qu'à
attendre que ça que ça que ça lui joue
tout doucement je fais maintenant sa
malle temps forts on va le retirer du
grand feu attendez vous servir des
salles bien voilà merci et on va laisser
mijoter pendant une heure une heure et
demie à 1h à 1h30 temps météo c'est long
quand même bon que les morceaux sont
bien plus classe que la cherchez des
tâches bien series
ça aurait alors dit le lierre valait
presque prêt oui je vais mettre mon sens
maintenant c'est le sens que vous avez
récupéré au moment
c'est d'ailleurs avec le centre chez
meilleur oui quand on a là mais n'a pas
toujours pas toujours leur qui perd et
ça dépend de la façon dont il est tué
oui le sort n'est pas indispensable mais
si vous avez pu le récupérer
sachez que pour le garder liquide il
faut y mettre tout de suite un filet de
vinaigre
on peut aussi au dernier moment en même
temps que le 100 mètres le foie dans la
cocotte
voilà ils voulaient ces sept minutes
alors on a l'art dit ça y est ça y est
j'ai placé cette fois seuls 51 points
maintenant on va pouvoir les manger nous
ensemble en famille et bien entendu tout
de suite si vous voulez allez-y
attention c'est peut-être pas le profil
et leur métier en plein vol d'hier
redire et voilà le 6 mai je pense que
c'est interdit je suis sûr qu'ils n'ont
pas d'autres avant avec tout ce que vous
avez mis dedans
avec votre expérience d'où sûrement
combien d'années dans la pratique du cv
ohlala voilà tellement longtemps que je
m'en rappelle plus et vous avez appris
dans 7 à vous oui j'espère qu'elle
continue et dix enfants et petits
enfants et là vous êtes petites filles
et chez vous aussi vous prête le civet à
la façon dont les mardis bon à mardi je
vous laisse travailler savais pas ce que
ça veut dire qu'il a pris au fond enfin
à le dire quand même bon mais
normalement il prend pas au fond avec de
bien les règles est passé de siècle il
n'y a pas de façon particulière de
manger vous y auriez alors non non le
lait infantile est cuit alors soit vous
ne mangerez tout de suite mais moi je le
préfère quand il a 8 10 ou de cuisson
avant ils posent ils peuvent garder si
longtemps a oui et puis même pas oubliée
un lien dans dans la pièce comme ça
bien sûr elle maintenant alors vous le
laissez puis deux jours après vous la
faites les tremper légèrement et vous
leur mettez dans la zone rouge mais dans
une pièce vous libyen il recueille un
détail non on ne verrait je fais tous
les deux jours allez plus de réchauffer
meilleur il est ouais mais d'ailleurs sa
hotte même parce que là avec du bio main
sa placidité quand même mais enfin ça
lui coupons corsa lui ôte la cgt qui
parle quand il est revenu fort et
meilleur
malheureusement c'est du gie berck qui
en voie de disparition
le lièvre à avoir eu difficile à trouver
il y en a de moins en moins ici on avait
dans le temps
à l'ouverture par exemple n'étaient pas
à peine de tuer trois ktm et maintenant
pour les manches il fait la passion
l'amour pourtant pas beaucoup passé à
l'ovale raté quand il passait il ya
intérêt on va pas rater cela non plus
celui à apporter aujourd'hui le français
n'a jamais osé nommer
[Musique]